[موسيقى]
نحييكم من جديد قائد قوات الدعم السريعه
السودانيه اللواء محمد حمدان ديجلو يشدد
على عدم التراجع عن الحكم المدني والتحول
الديمقراطي ويحذر من الوقوف ضد اي شخص
يرفض هذا الامر تصريحات ديلو شهير بحميتي
جاءت لدى مخاطبته حشدا من قواته في قاعده
كرري العسكريه شمال العاصمه الخرطوم هدد
بانه لن يقبل باي شخص يطمح بان يصبح
ديكتاتورا لحكم السودان وفق قوله واوضحا
قائد قوه الدعم السريع ذات النفوذ الواسع
اوضح ان الخلافه الرئيسي في البلاد الان
يتركز بين من وصفهم بالمكرسين للسلطه وبين
من يريدون تسليمها للمدنيين كما نفى حميد
في وجود اي خلاف بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني مؤكدا ان مبدا تشكيل
حكومه مدنيه قد تم بالاتفاق بين الجيش
والدعم السريع ومجلس السياده تصريحات حميد
هذه تاتي في سياق حرب كلاميه اشتعلت بين
الطرفين خلال الاسابيع الماضيه وكان قائد
الجيش الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد
قوه الدعم السريع قد تواصلوا الى توقيع
الاتفاق الايطالي مع القوه المدنيه
وبرعايه امنيه واقليميه في الخامس من
ديسمبر الماضي حيث تم الافتراض انه سيسمح
بتشكيل حكومه مدنيه
[موسيقى]
ما في مشكله بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مشكله بين الناس المكرسين بالسلطه الناس
اللي قاعدين مكنكشين والناس الدارين
يسلموا السلطه للحكومه المدنيه
وارادتنا ان احنا كنا نسلم
الحكومه الحكومه مدنيه كامله تلتزموا
ده المشكله بس هنا لكن الجيش اللي عنده
مشكله للدعم عنده مشكله لشرطه عندها مشكله
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من الخرطوم
الدكتور يعقوب عبد الكريم نورين والساده
العلاقه الدوليه والاتصال اهلا بك من
الخرطوم كذلك بعد قليل سيكون معنا اللواء
معتصم عبد القادر الحسن الخبير الامني
والعسكري اهلا بكم ضيوفي سابدا معك دكتور
يعقوب دكتور يعقوب مشادات كلاميه وحديث
وراء الابواب المغلقه تتحدث عن خلاف عميق
بين
البرهان مع حفظ الالقاب طبعا
وهناك كلام
ينتقد فيه كل طرف الاخر بانه لا يدعم
ويعرقل المسار السياسي
اي الاراء نصدق خاصه في هذه المرحله
اولا شكرا جزيلا على هذه الاستضافه
وتحياتي لك في يوم المراه العالمي شكرا
جزيتي لكل الامهات والبنات والاخوات ان
شاء الله اولا هذه التصريحات هي امتداد
لتصريحات الفريق اول البرهان بدايه
خروجه من البيان الشهير الاصدره وبموجب
قال خرجت المؤسسه العسكريه من العمليه
السياسيه وتركت الامر للمدنيين لتشكيل
حكومه وهكذا هذا الامر كان في البدايه
متفق عليه بين قياده القوات المسلحه كلها
اذا كان الجيشة والدعم السريع وكل القوات
كانت متفقه على هذا الامر
الوصول ولكن لا اعتقد ان هنالك اي قدره
لاي طرف لاجعال الوضع في السودان والذي لم
تكون مقبوله ومعتصم اذا كان هذا الكلام
دقيق لماذا سارع البرهان في تشكيل المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه قبل تشكيله للمجلس
المدني ويقول البعض بانه من خلال هذه
الخطوه هو محاوله تعديل المسار ومحاوله في
خطوه اخرى او تاليه محاوله تحجيم حضور
حماتي
التي تطلق ما بين الفين والاخرى من اي طرف
من الاطراف تتم في الظروف معينه في ظل قد
يكون هنالك حشد عسكري
ولكن عن اي ظروف نتحدث نحن نتحدث عن
تصريحات لمسؤولين نحن نتحدث عن ابرز
شخصيتين عسكريتين في داخل السوداني نحن
نتحدث عن تصريحات لزعيم الدعم السريع
لحمايه الذي يقول في بطريقه واضحه وصريحه
بان هناك اطراف في الجيش يعرقلون الانتقال
المدني خليني اسمع منك دكتور يعقوب انت
تتحدث عن ان هذه التصريحات يجب ان تبقى
داخل الغرف المغلقه ولكن ليس الاعلام من
يعني نشرها حماتي هو الذي صرح بها
اولا اولا الخطاب الفريق حمايه الاخير هو
يعني عنده فوائد كثيره جدا جدا اول حاجه
فيهم انه ازال الهاجس والخوف الكان في
نفوس المواطنين وفي نفوس الشعب السوداني
والخائفين من وقوع حرب ما بين الدعم
السريع والجيش اول حاجه الكلام ده بقى غير
موجود ودي رساله اطمئنان لكل الشعب
السوداني ده واحد اثنين اكد على ان
المؤسسه العسكريه يجب ان تلتزم بما
تعهدت به وهو الخروج من العمليه السياسيه
وتركها للمدنيين وتشكيل حكومه مدنيه
مستقله من كفاءات وطنيه معروف هذا الامر
منتهي اذا لماذا الناس تصير على ان تؤخر
هذا الامر الان منذ توقيع الاتفاق الاطار
الى الان هنالك عرقله لتوقيع
للمضي قدما في هذا الاتفاق الايطالي يجب
ان ينفذ هذا الاتفاق الايطالي وتخرج
المؤسسه العسكريه
معروفه يعني هو الان يعني الفريق البرهان
في تصريحه الاخير قال انه يعني احنا عشان
نمشي في الاتفاق الايطالي لابد من دمج
الدعم السريع هذا الامر اصلا الدعم السريع
اصلا هو قوه في داخل الجيش السوداني ويتبع
للقائد العام ويتلقى تعليماته من القائد
العام الذي يمثله الفريق البرهان رئيس
السياده اذا ما في حاجه اسمها الدعم
السريع والدمج في الجيش وكده عشان تبقى
يعني سبب في تاخير وتعرقله العمليه
السياسيه في السودان يعني فالامر ايضا هو
الالتزام الاخلاقي مع الشعب السوداني من
قاده الجيش وقاده قوات الدعم السريع في ان
يسلم السلطه الى حكومه مدنيه هذا هو
الالتزام الاخلاقي الذي يجب ان ينبغي فيه
كل جميعهم للاخر وضحت الفكره ومعتصم هكذا
ترى الموضوع يتلخص في تصريحات البرهان
التي دعا فيها الى دمج دعم السريع
داخل مؤسسه الجيش
دعم دعم دمج الدعم السريع ودمج قوات
الحركات المسلحه التي وقعت على اتفاقيه
جوبا هذه مساله اساسيه لخلق الاستقرار في
البلاد اذا ان هذه المساله لا اعتقد انه
في ظل اي حكومه انتقاليه يمكن ان يكون لها
القدره على السيطره على هذه القوه
وهذه النقطه واضحه في الواقع تصريحات
البرهان واضحه سؤالي كان هل هذه هي نقطه
الخلاف بين طرفين
الخلاف بين الطرفين انا اعتقد لم يعلن اي
من الطرفين ان اي تفاصيل لاي خلاف كلما
كلما يبرز في الساحه ان هنالك
هذا انا اعتقد ان هذا تصريح سياسي يمكن ان
يختلف الناس معه ان الطرف الاخر لا يعرقل
الاتفاق المدني ولا يعرقل المسار المدني
ولكن هذه مسائل اولويات واسبقيات يجب ان
يجلس الناس ويتفاوضوا في وضعها والوصول
الى
اتفاق حولها وكذلك هذه تصريح هذا الصبغه
سياسيه انا اعتقد يعني يجب والمزايا
السياسيه لا تناقش
بالاتفاقيات ولكن هو معتصم ما تقوله قد
يبدو اخطر لاننا لما نتحدث عن خلاف بين
شخصيتين عسكريتين على اطار سياسي فهناك
شيء ربما يرتب في داخل السوداني ما رايك
دكتور يعقوب
من اي ناحيه الشيء الذي يرطب في الداخل من
اي ناحيه ضيف يقول بان هذه التصريحات هي
تصريحات سياسيه بالاساس تصريحات حماتي هي
تصريحات يمكن ان نضعها في اطار سياسي
فسالت ما الاطار السياسي الذي يمكن ان
يختلف عليه شخصين في هذه المرحله وفي هذا
التوقيت
اول حاجه تصريحات الفريق حميتي ليست
تصريحات سياسيه بالمعنى الواضح وانما هي
تنوير للراي العام السوداني والعالمي بان
هذا الامر هو امر الاختلاف مع المكنكشين
الكلام التي الكلام الذي ذكر ما عندكم في
التقرير في بدايه الحوار
والمكنكشين ديل اللي هم
الذين يريدون يستاثروا بالسلطه
والسودان الان الان تاخر اربع سنوات كان
يمكن ان يمضي الى الامام ولكن انا افتكر
انه التصريحات الفريق حميدتي هي تصريحات
لوضح لشرح الغلاف الموجود للراي العام
المحلي والراي العمل عالم والاغليمي عشان
يوريهم الامر ماشي وين من هم الذين
يعرقلون هذا الانتقال هو اكد جاهزيته لكل
الخطوات التي جاءت في الاتفاق الايطالي
واكد دعمه للعمليه التحول الديمقراطي في
السودان واكد كذلك التزامه بحمايه الفتره
الانتقاليه فانا افتكر هذا الامر قطع قول
لكل خطيب يعني كذلك بعد ما في حاجه غير
انه الناس
تنتظم القوى السياسيه وتضع ملامح الحكومه
المقبله والجيش ينسحب ويذهب الى المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه او غيره شرفي هذا
هو الذي يصحح ولكن دكتور يعقوب لما تقول
حضرتك بان هذه التصريحات المراد منها هو
تحذير الجهه التي تتمسك بالسلطه نتحدث عن
المجلس السيادي
نعم المجلس السيادي هم اعضاء فيه لا
يريدون لا يريدون الامر ان يمضي في
الاتجاه السليم نحو التحول الديمقراطي
وهذا معلوم بالضروره لكل الناس يعني هم
الان يعلمون يعلمون ذلك وتصريحاتهم تؤكد
ذلك ايضا
حتى الاخ الضيفي الكريم يتحدث عن السودان
ليس غرفه يسلم بمعنى ماذا يعني هذا يعني
من الذي يملك السودان حتى يسلمه او لا
يسلمهم السودان هذا ملك للشعب السوداني
شعب السوداني الذي خرج في ثوره
شهد عليها كل العالم وبالتالي هذا الشعب
هو الذي يملك السلطه وهو الذي يقرر في
مسيرتها وسير الدوله السودانيه اذا الجيش
والدعم السريع والقوات الامنيه هي جزء من
هذا الشعب عليها ان تلتزم وتستجيب لصوت
الشعب
لواء معتصم من كان لك تعليق
انا تعليقي ان هذه مسائل اجرائيه لماذا
لماذا جلس الناس او جلست القوه السياسيه
ووضعت اتفاق اطاري
وتتفاوض الان الكتله الديمقراطيه مع
المجلس المركزي هذه مسائل اجرائيه هذه
المسائل لا تتم في الهواء هكذا يعني هذه
المسائل لا تتم في الهواء هذه مسائل عمليه
لها اجراءات عمليه ولكن كما ذكرت لك ما
دام ليس هنالك خلاف مع الجيش هذا يعني ان
الاختلاف سياسي يعني اختلاف ليس عسكريا
ولن يؤدي الى اي التهاب ولن يؤدي الى اي
اشتعال على الناس ان تجلس انا اعتقد ان
الان السلطه على السلطه اذا ذكرنا المكون
العسكري واذا ذكرنا جزء منه الدعم السريع
والحركات وقوه الحركات هذه الان الجهات
المكونه للسلطه في السودان كلها مكنكشه
انا اعتقد انهم حتى اذا ارادوا ان يتركوا
الشرطه يجب ان يتركوها ان يجلسوا ان
يتفاوضوا عن كيفيه تقديم للسلطه صحيح وضحت
الفكره وشكركم من جزيل الشكر من الخرطوم
اللي هو معتصم عبد القادر الحسن الخبير
الامني والعسكري ومن الخرطوم دائما
الدكتور يعقوب عبد الكريم نورين استاذ
العلاقه الدوليه والاتصال شكرا جزيلا